welcome back to omix logic where we  simplify bioinformatics and help make  onyx data analysis logical in this short  video we will discuss genomics what is  genomic data how is it organized  analyzed and interpreted to be such a  powerful resource in the hands of  clinicians researchers and entrepreneurs  that are reading the dna code to battle  cancer fight off infectious diseases and  even solve crimes let's start by  reviewing some of the fundamentals of  genomics genomics is all about dna so  what is dna code what do we already know  about it and what kind of answers can we  find in this kind of code how can we  analyze huge sequences of nucleotides  stored in the dna and how do we make  sense of them if you're interested to  learn more we recommend using the word  genomics on this portal as you search  for lessons practical tutorials and  project examples as a result you will be  able to learn the theories behind  genomics and practice analyzing genomic  data on your own